-Hi, Jimmy, how are you?
-Thank you for coming on. Thanks for playing the game.
I want to talk about all these -- all this exciting news.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. There's a lot going on.
-It's -- It's a lot. -Breaking news.
-I mean, you're -- you're acting, but you're also
producing all these multiple projects.
-Yeah.
-"Russian Doll" season two, it started today.
-Yeah, yeah. It's now streaming. Yeah.
And, uh -- Cheers and applause ]
So... -You know what, by the way?
I -- I follow you on the socials.
-Oh. -Yeah, because, you know.
Well, you're very funny. -No, no, I'm going to
follow back eventually.
-Thank you, yeah, yeah.
I just wanted to put it -- say it out loud on live television.
But, you know, I didn't realize --
you love the game Wordle, by the way.
I don't know if you know this.
-Oh, I do. -You love it.
-I do feel terrible, 'cause I feel like
these nice people are following,
and they're hoping for something,
but it's just really my Wordle and Quordle and Octordle
and Sedecordle and Duotrigordle scores.
-Yeah.
-Duotrigordle is a lot of fun you see,
because it's 32 grids at once.
-That's too many for me. -It's just the right amount.
-It really --
-Really? That's where you want to go?
-Oh, that's that sweet spot, Jimmy.
-What do you love about it?
"Ooh, that's that sweet spot, Jimmy."
-How do you -- why do you love Wordle game?
Why do you love those --
-Eh, you know, I like to hear the click,
the white-noise sound, the click.
And when you tap the buttons, you feel like a cat.
It also incorporates...
[ Laughter ]
...reading and words, which I like, and tapping.
And it's not exclusive to that.
I also enjoy chess and the crossword
and the "New York Times" Spelling Bee.
-Wait. -So I have a lot of hobbies.
-Wait. -I do it all on the phone.
I'm essentially a cyborg, at this point.
And I'm doing, at least,
I would say four to six hours a day of gaming.
-Oh, wow. Congratulations. Oh, my God.
-Thank you so much.
-You got to get a Twitch channel next.
-Yeah. And I also -- I beat "Zelda" during the pandemic.
-Oh, wasn't that unbelievable? -Yeah, I'm getting a lot done.
-Look at you! I love this! -Yeah.
And the show is out today. -And there you go, yeah.
And it's out today. -So that's great.
-You know, I've known you for a long time,
love everything you do.
"Orange is the New Black." Congratulations. That was great.
And then you go, "Yeah, I'm gonna come up with this idea
for 'Russian Doll' and produce it with Amy Poehler...
-Yeah. -...and just figure this out."
How did you even -- how did you sell the idea of "Russian Doll"?
-Oh, I'm not sure how we sold it.
I guess the algorithm. Um, but --
-It's great. You did a fantastic job with it.
-Aw. Thank you so much. We work very hard.
I really hope you guys like it.
But, well what happened back --
Well, I've known you guys because of Maya --
-Yeah. -You and Amy and Fred
and everything for like 25 years or something now.
-Wild.
-And -- And one day Amy called me.
I was at home. I was watching "NYPD Blue."
I was on a real bender.
I'm a little bit in love with Dennis Franz as Andy Sipowicz.
-Oh, I remember. -I just think he's a real cutie.
And, uh --
So, I was watching that,
you know, eating ice cream and chicken.
And she calls me up and she says,
"Hey, I just wanted to say, as long as I've known you,
you've always been the oldest girl in the world."
And I said, "Why are you calling and insulting me?"
-"I don't have time for this. Please."
-"I'm having a tough enough time as it is, Amy."
-"I'm hanging up the phone now. Why would you say that?"
-She said, "I think we should make a show about that."
And so we made that show. "Old Soul."
It didn't get picked up.
But then we made "Russian Doll."
And -- Yeah. -Wow.
-And so -- Now streaming, like I said.
-So "Russian Doll" -- And it was --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I loved it. I go, "That was trippy."
You did -- You just played it so well.
But it's basically like a "Groundhog Day" type of vibe,
where you kept dying each episode
and then reliving your -- your birthday.
But what is season two about?
-Yes, well, this year, it's a bit of a deeper dive.
If you think of the matryoshka doll,
there's, you know, ever deeper dolls inside of there.
And so if season one
was sort of a meditation on "how do I stop dying?",
in a way, season two is posing the question of,
"How do I start living?"
So it's -- it kind of gets in --
It's a real psychedelic, philosophical romp,
and if that's your scene, you'll really enjoy yourself.
-Yeah. -It's a wild ride.
I cannot believe they let us make it.
-Yeah. -Yeah.
-Yeah, it looks great.
I know Annie Murphy joined the cast, too.
-Yeah, Annie Murphy is a sensation.
-She's fantastic. You guys together? Forget it.
-Oh, my God. And she looks like a Scorsese character in this.
I mean, she is just -- does excellent work.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is Natasha Lyonne in "Russian Doll," season two.
-Can I get a bourbon?
-A bourbon? You sure about that, hon?
-Yeah, "hon." That's arguably the only thing I'm sure of.
Basic concepts like time and space are suddenly eluding me.
I mean, last night, this place was mayhem cause Wi-Fi went out,
but in the new here and now,
apparently gratuitous nudity is back in play.
Well, my past, your future.
Begs the question... am I haunting you...
or are you haunting me?
-You seem pretty relaxed for a ghost.
-Tell you what I did not expect --
It's for the 6 train
to run through some kind of a worm hole.
Hit me, please.
-You're a time traveler.
-Eh. I prefer the term "time prisoner."
-Hm. -Yeah, come on.
Come on, buddy.
I also want to say,
you got to -- you got to direct some of these.
-Oh, yeah, yeah. I direct about half the season.
And, you know, we write it,
and we've got a pretty sensational thing --
an all-ladies writers' room.
They're geniuses. I swear to God.
-Hey. I'm so happy for you. -Yeah, yeah.
-Thanks for coming on. It's always so great to see you.
Natasha Lyonne, everybody. Check out the new season
of "Russian Doll," streaming right now on Netflix.